hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
high resolution imaging of zebrafish at
nano and millimeter scale
i am jennifer woods of labrus and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by andor
to learn more visit andor.com we
encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
julian
resigier post doctoral fellow university
of oslo
and dr claudia florindo product
specialist
life sciences and or technology
doctor refigure you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the very kind
introductions so good morning everyone
it's a real pleasure to be with you
today and i will
uh present you uh my work on high
resolution imaging
of zebrafish at nano on millimeter
scales so
just a few words about me first so i'm a
positive fellow
for the university of oslo for the group
of professor garrett griffiths for whom
i conducted two
research topics one on the behavior of
therapeutic nanoparticles
on the interaction with the vasculature
and especially how they accumulate
in disease related to angiogenesis
and also the second topic is more to the
characterization
of the structural organization of fish
because of immunity with a special focus
on the guild associated with tissue so
now we can start so basically uh in
those recent years
there have been many advances in imaging
whether it is a
new kind of microscopes such as the
light sheets or great improvements
of the complicated microscopes as a
conventional or spinning disk
they also benefited from a lot of
improvements
from the cameras that allows us to
acquire data at
much higher resolutions and sensitivity
of course when you have so much imaging
data you also need improvements
of the software so all these
improvements
uh allow us no scientists to
replace the molecular biology data into
the special context
but the thing is a lot of the imaging
advances
benefited a lot the in vitro studies as
you can see with this very nice
picture of the future with the dragonfly
the problem is
in some fields there is some kind of a
gap between the in vitro studies
on the next step the indivo and
there is a current need to strengthen
this bridge especially for fields such
as nanotechnology and vascular biology
which are
complex um but
are about complex 3d structures on
environment
and within that one of the problem with
these situations
is well the most model is the most
prominent model used at the moment by
the scientists
but it shows civil limitations for the
magic
and we just go past all the
practicability
things still those people have been able
to
are very nice uh live imaging in mice
with introductory
imaging however the problem is this
is a very invasive method so either you
just induce
inflammatory conditions into your
experiment or you have to put
anti-inflammatory drugs
and still with that it remains difficult
to secure
at the same time a very nice high
special on-time resolution
so basically uh we have these situations
when most people
look into in vitro studies and cells and
directly switch to individual in
mammalian systems
and we think that a lot of research
would benefit
by adding an interdimensional model to
the mammogram systems
or to use a complementary model to them
and we think that
one of the scientific model animal model
that
is on the rise at the moment and i
benefit a lot from all these advances
for imaging
is the zebrafish well it's highly
available
accessible it is incredibly practical
because of its small size um
as you can see to the right here the
larvae
of the zebrafish are fully developed by
d3 but also they're transparent
when you add small drugs there's a lot
of tools
that have been developed and it is
particularly more accepted
than mammalian systems but it's not just
about practicability
um the zebrafish is like show high
degree of conservations with mammals
seventy percent of human genes
are nautolog in zebrafish it has a
complex immune system sensitive to
toxicity
so actually a lot of people start to use
the zebrafish model
for genetics developmental studies
neurosciences
abdomens what is put on the rise is
human disease models for infections
cancers
or other biological mechanisms but i
think that
what makes this model the most appealing
at the moment on why
the community using zebrafish grow and
grow is because of two parameters
it allows it's very good for live
imaging on wall organism observations
and the reason why is those two things
has everything to do with preservation
of the biological context
when you want to address complex
scientific questions
you want to have the perfect almost
optimal
vertical context for light imaging you
don't have fixation artifact
you can observe life what is happening
you can see the cell moving what it does
and if you go for world organism
observations you don't need to dissect
things so you don't do any damage
you can keep all the connections between
the organs if you want to study systemic
tissues
vascular lymphatic systems nervous
system or even bones
it's very good and also to be able to
check
on the organism level is that allows you
that gives you the opportunity to
explore other order but okay i want to
study the liver
but maybe i would find something
unexpected in the organ nearby in the
clinic for example
you don't know but this actually allows
you to do it
so if you go a bit more into the live
imaging now
um so it said it's the zebrafish is
heavily used
for drug screenings for cancer fields
for example a group
in portugal by the professor return is
injecting
um cancer cells from patients into the
zebrafish larvae and then she evaluates
how they respond to drugs to
chemotherapy agent
there's a lot of people working to study
host pathogen interactions
on virus for example with chikungunya
virus
and even though there is preference
about the coronavirus
so by the group of elena sadinas pierre
boudino and jean-pierre lebron
uh there is a laboratory in netherlands
by maria folenza led by maya folenza
that to the trypanosome sitting sickness
into zebrafish and then she can actually
study all the baby aid in the blood and
infiltrate the tissues and in our case
uh we use the zebrafish also
to study bacterial infections we have
model of tuberculosis
so if i were to slightly present so here
you have a zebrafish lobby so we have
the head right here on the tail
to the right you can inject
the equivalent of the tobacco this
bacterial fish which is called
mycobacterium mariner into
the spinal cord called neural tubes at
this stage
and here is very thick granuloma in
black
and if you understand the bacteria here
in green
magenta you see that this area is full
of bacteria
on the nice things with the dry zone 5
so one thing is most of the data will
benefit today
the very huge majority comes from the
dragonfly 500
like this video right here so we have
fish
where the neutrophils are green
fluorescents and the microphages are red
fluorescent
and then you could acquire the world
volume of the granuloma and then you
could follow
the behavior of the cells and see that
there is one ear
that that front button macrophage in red
will eat a neutrophils
and its cytosol would turn yellow and
then it will die
you see start to be yellow
and then up it will pop out and die very
quickly there
so that's the advantages of the
zebrafish but it's also very good for
the fields like
nanoparticle studies here um
we it's a video that where we used a
fluorescent
uh nanoparticles from the laboratory of
materials bars in the netherlands
so basically a very tiny nanoparticles
the rounds are worm-like on the
incredibly fluorescent so here
we'll be about actually to see videos
like you can see the particles but you
see that all the presents in
white is from the particles and the nice
things
is that it reveals negative all the red
blood cells
only if you wonder what all these blood
things are in the red blood cells
in fish red blood cells are nucleated
as is the case for some camel species
so just let you enjoy a bit uh when you
push the dragonfly to its limits on
speed acquisitions
how good is the image and you can see
the red blood cells are
bending and bumping into each other so
let's find it very nice
anyway if we continue a bit um
i will present you uh a bit more like oh
we could use
the zebrafish model uh to actually
make some findings on the nanoparticle
seeds and to actually find
uh a new mechanisms at play that
actually interacts
or actually alter the fate of
intravenously injected nanoparticles
so it all starts uh with the dr bernard
in france on his group in the cnrs on
its associated
uh startup called agilities so what
they're doing is basically they created
uh what's called safe by design
polymeric nanoparticles just to be quick
it's just
nanoparticles that are made in a way
in a proactive way to prevent any issues
with human health
so for example they're just made of
plain dla there is no surfactant
and also all the residual solvents are
in accordance with the european
pharmacopoeia
they have a very small size 200
nanometers and they are highly stable
and the thing with this particle is they
are biodegradable by a compatible
and bioresorb level an effective okay
that's nice none but what do they look
so basically those particles they are
made of
interlacing polymer chains as you can
see in this artistic visions
but if we look uh by electron microscopy
technique so here in scanning electron
microscopy on in those two image
with negative stain by transmission
electron microscopy
they just look like some very tiny ovary
beads
but as you can see to the right this
black dots as actually because
in those particles we encapsulated
smaller nanoparticles made of gold
which are dense to the electrons because
but one thing which is very interesting
with nanoparticles is that
you can trap compounds in the matrix of
the nanoparticles
for example drugs adjudants or even
fluorophore to make the nanoparticle
presence
and in addition to that you can also add
some other compounds at the surface
so they use these nanoparticles for
different
uh therapeutic applications from
vaccines because of vaccines
direct delivery on in the recent years
they have been very good at making
customs and marinated livery
but they are not through doing vaccines
and other kind of treatments with it
the questions when i came in it was like
uh okay it works
on the property level but oakland will
further optimize the therapeutic
applications
um one way to do it is actually to try
to better understand
what are the interactions of the
nanoparticle of just the carrier
with the organisms on its face
so the main question will be oh or did
it behave in the blood first of all if
you inject it
uh what will happen so we add red
fluorescent
nanoparticles or we can solve other
colors that we injected
in uh baby zebrafish into the
circulation
and then we could actually just um
see with live imaging okay all the
nanoparticles goes
so the first thing we did was with a
sterile microscope and you can see the
nanoparticle here
in magenta and the endocrine cells in
green because this fish is strong genic
so all the underpill cells express the
green gfp green persons
but you can see with stereo microscope
the resolution is not very good it seems
to mimic the circulation
of the vascular system but you can't
really tell if it's associated
inside you don't know so in this case we
went to the spinning disc comfortable
microscope
and as you can see here it's just a very
nice blood vessel the resolution is
it's at a new level it's not comparable
so we then looked actually we
investigated several overlapping
editions
where would we see the nanoparticles so
in this image here
you have a maximum intensity projections
when you would see the vein
of the fish on right ear and archery
you can see all the nanoparticles in
magenta so it seems associated to it but
then
you can just open the stack and go with
the optical section
and then you see that the nanoparticles
are actually really inside
down the fuel cells not at the surface
interestingly so if you look there
the nanoparticle does not mix with the
cytosol which means they are restricted
to the on the city compartment
and other things we could see is that in
addition to be internalized by
undertale cells we could spot some
phagocytes
in the lumen also some of them have been
a tiny bit of gfp
we then wonder okay but uh what's the
dynamic of that
how long does it take for the
nanoparticle to be internalized and
cleared from the blood
so then we made live imaging or we
injected and immediately go to the
microscope
on that you can see the nanoparticles
circulating and we see that
by around 20 minutes almost nothing
remains
in the blood circulation so this is data
we could confirm afterward with
electron microscopy so we know a bit
more what happened on the
on the vascular on the other fuel cell
side but then okay so we seems to have
some phagocytes in the bloods
so we looked at neutrophils first with
green for some obstacles and we didn't
see anything
so then we looked at macrophages and we
use the trosinic line where macrophages
are red fluorescent so in this picture
here
you have the vein right here on the arch
right over there
the nanoparticles are in cyan and the
macrophage is in right flavor
sense and we could recompose with mres
all the 3d structures all the 3d of the
microphages and then you could open up
and say okay
here we have some microphotos yes we see
the nanoparticles so let me internalize
it
so what we notified that okay the
nanoparticles
are quickly internalized by on the field
cells on macrophages
um by 20 30 minutes so then we try to
look okay but
uh what will happen over time so we try
instead of using live imaging in this
case we
we made like a section for the organism
of the larvae
and we looked okay uh here we stand for
the nuclei in blue
we have the blood vessels in green on
the nanoparticles in magenta so all the
sections to the left
are transformation this way so you can
see the notochord
you can see the muscles you have the
altar right here
the network of veins and then those two
rounds here
there are the kidneys and then you have
the developing intestines on the yolk
right to the right all these are a
longitudinal section
through the the major vein
on artery so basically what we see that
thereby
biodistribution looks very stable
nothing really happened
the only thing we could see actually is
that some clusterization of the
nanoparticle around nuclei
but also at the 24 hour time we could
spot
some phagocytes evenly loaded with
nanoparticles that we are not seeing at
the 30 minute or four-hour
site well that was a bit intriguing
so we literally saw the same thing with
features so here we look at the main
veins
and basically from 10 minutes 30 minutes
4 hours on 24 hours
there is not really changes just the
ceiling side microphages
although it felt that still look like
the 24 would seem that
maybe that they may have a bit more but
yeah maybe it's just uh
the feeling nothing real so we continued
um i would not build all the data here
but we tried to look and see
they go into the vasculature but could
they go
to what we call off-target accumulation
sites i want them to go to the blood but
would they reach the brain
whether it's the liver on other organs
so then we looked at the brain and we
could see that at 30 minutes
on forwards the nanoparticles are
restricted to the underfield cells
they do not cross the blood-brain
barrier
while at 24 hours most of them were
still restricted to the underfuel cells
we also again started to see
phagocytes heavily loaded with
nanoparticles
um that was a bit strange and also we
could identify that those cells
are macrophages or microglia
okay so we three seems to have something
different with the macrophages of the
time
so then we try to figure out okay
what's the dynamic of internalization by
the macrophages
so we should look between 30 minutes
time points and 24 times some points
at the quantity of thunder particle
inside microphones and we could actually
see that
although there is no more nanoparticles
circulating at 30 minutes
the macrophages still internalize
nanoparticles
and also we looked by phosnitometry at
the fraction
of macrophages positive to nanoparticles
so you see like a slight increase from
10 minutes to 30 minutes but that
thirteenth is
nothing is circulating anymore but still
more and more macrophages get positive
for the nanoparticles so
okay how do they do or does the
macrophages internalize
nanoparticles they should not be
available to them like all of this
is inside of your cells are already in
macrophages
so for that we went with uh high
resolution live imaging so we're
injecting
nanoparticles into the circulations
and then we went to this little area of
the zebrafish lobby
called the york circulation valley
because you already have
you have very very thin tissues before
the blood compartment so it is ideal for
high resolution imaging
so basically what is composed you have
like the epidermis
a small basement membrane a layer of
under filled cells the blood
circulations
on the yolk sensitive layer and if we're
looking for some disease or eclipse so
if you have in green
this layer of undertale cells you have
some nanoparticles in white
on the macrophages in red so you also a
lot of macrophages
um during life imaging in this area we
could figure out at one point like we
have several set of videos where
uh it seemed that microsoft microphotos
would go in contact
are pretty close to the endothelium and
at one point we would see a transfer
of uh of gfp and nanoparticle from the
underscore cells
to the macrophage but i think you would
see it better in the small videos to the
right
so it will be this macrophage here see
it starts to go in contact
click close down color the front put
here there takes up
a chunk of gfp on nanoparticles
so quickly uh we look into the
into the stack of the videos on ck at
the moment it's internalize
the nanoparticles the the gfp there's
already nanoparticles in the gfp
so they get a chunk of the underfuel
cells apparently
with nanoparticle inside but that the
nanoparticle inside are still inside on
the city compartment
and we looked a bit after on safety then
the microphage match everything you see
the gsp signal getting lower because it
is being quenched by the acidity
of the compartment or some gfp seems to
be expelled
by the cell so the thing like that was
very unexpected um
it seemed that just microphysical just
like newer bits of
macrophages of undertale cells and we
didn't know this mechanism it was never
reported before
so basically what we what we reported in
this publication like okay we don't
really know what happened there
exactly but we know that at the end you
have the macrophages
that internalize an anonymously
compartment gfp
that does not merge with the plural
force inside the cytosol
of the macrophage with the red and that
you have the nanoparticle inside the
city compartment
so if we look it to the mechanistic then
it excludes everything which is
exocytosis related
okay so what could transfer onto acidic
compartments
because genetics nanotubes could do it
but in this case you would have a direct
transfer on mix of the two fluorophores
so
that does not work out um well could be
maybe it was
um hypothesis related events but maybe
there was ephesus from a dying
endothelial cell i said like yeah the
problem is
the donor cell in the videos we we are
they stay alive they don't die and there
is no dying cells around
and then when we looked um at the cell
they've induced
by the injection of nanoparticles uh
besides the mecha the mechanical injury
of injecting
you don't see anything so it's unlikely
to be
uh apoptosis related but we think
uh what would have to prove that is that
it might be related
or to trigocytosis but initially
tropocytosis were described
by exchange of plasma brain between
neutrons but between
lymphocytes but the thing is
more people started to look into
macrophages and they seem but in
microfiche they can
neos especially with adipocytes a chunk
of adipocyte
on the transfer material is then
internalized instead of remaining at the
plasma membrane
so still the identification of this
mechanism
is the topic of further studies but
still like
very interesting because it seems that
you have the mechanisms
that were not expected for the
for the nanoparticles and it's very
important to try to understand okay oh
it works because
maybe we could explore this for foreign
applications for example
to target nanoparticles to the brain
macrophages are michoglia which are
actually involved
in a neurogeneric neurodegenerative
disease
so that was quite interesting then uh we
tried to look
also uh at these at least all these
pathways
um on these models so first of all uh on
concert
if we show here with this publication we
published last year
we can actually infect uh zebrafish
lobby
with cancer cells melanoma cells you see
in orange in right here
and you see that when we do that we have
a glorious um androgenesis
presumably more you see here and in blue
you have quantum dots just to show that
all these vessels are functionals
and of course we also look into
uh the granulomatosis models but
unfortunately there is no time to
present all this
so that's the four parts about slide
imaging and i would start to
go a bit more into the the world
organism observations
so basically in this case it's more
about the adult zebrafish
so basically something i do for my
research
is i would make cryo sections through
the length of the zebrafish so
with kernel section and you see that in
the block
everything is preserved we have the
ovaries the intestines
the the gills are the eld the tail idiot
of the art so everything would be
preserved
and then you can make some kind of
different stainings for example
with folluding to reveal all the actins
aren't that it for the
nuclei on just those two
the pattern of actin staining on from
nuclei
will give you a lot of information to
identify which tissue you're in and
which cell type you're looking at
and in this case in acquisition to the
right here
uh the answer says the blood the cells
in particular cells and junctions
are in green uh fluorescence and then
i'll just
follow the videos you can see uh from
this three multiple
field of view acquisition that you have
access you can identify
the kidneys on the tubules
then you can navigate a bit more and
then you can see here this membrane that
separates
with the liver with melanocyte in black
then you have all the sinusoids
of the liver and you can see with all
this vasculature why
it is very dangerous to get injury in
the liver
it's uh it's mostly blood vessels on
hepatocytes
there you can see the ultimate bronchial
gland and then you just continue
then you have some muscles you will have
some bones here for example
and then you can follow the esophagus on
all this vasculature
and then if you look there then you
would have a nerve that is also
preserved a blood vessel on the
anastomatic vessels
around it so to to be able to make real
sections
to stain it and to uh to then use the
dragonfly
to to make very fast acquisitions of
multiple field of view
it's it's very nice to explore the right
areas and it's very good
to to look at just blood vessels
lymphatic vessels immune system bones
everything
so here i would probably show you so
here we have a fish
that is infected with a parasite fungi
called mycosporidia neophilia in fact
the most preferential sites are the iron
brain on the spinal cord
so here you have a corner section
through the fish that is made of 105
field of view
of a thickness of eight microns so just
to say this huge data
took one hour to acquire with estimates
so i can't imagine how long it would
have been
with the conventional microscope
on there you can see the eyes of course
then you have the nostrils
to the two sides when you see there are
surely
the nerves the olfactory bulb the
ventral parts of the tendoncephalon
the midbrain aren't the optic tectums
right here
then you go to the iron brain right here
you have vertebra
and then you have the spinal cord on
right here all the muscles
um when you then display the immune cell
this is what happens so of course you
see t cells
in the mucosal tissues the cornea the
nostrils
but then you see all the aggregates to
the iron brain aren't
close to the spinal cord so this you
would not see in a healthy fish
so really they are associated with these
apartheid infections but i think the
best thing is again
to illustrate it with video just to see
what resolution you can at
the resolution you achieve with such
imaging so here we focus
over the nose fields and you can see all
the t-cells individual cells
and then you can move around go into the
old factory build
yeah there it is with star wars mode
here you can continue then you can see
all the difference between the different
regions of the brain
you can see all these um red cells
that you will not see in the forwards
regions then you have the architecture
you see some t
cells in the meninges this is the ear
of the fish
again with a bit of t-cells some nails
you can see all the vasculature in the
in the muscles
i live as polarized and then again the
video will
focus um on the parts which are infected
by this parasite here you can see all
these parts here
that full of parasite of what you see is
full of spores
but again if you continue you will pass
the vertebrae
right here and then you continue to the
spinal cord and then you can also see
sack of spores
here on all the t cells around so this
is really like
triggers uh infiltration of immune cells
in the brain so you have to be careful
when you do
neurosciences to not have your fish
infected with these parasites
okay so no uh yeah yeah there's a few
one of the video i forgot about it
oh yeah we could also spot some local
infiltrations of lymphocytes in the
brain right here
so okay now let's go to the past say one
of my
research topic is to look actually into
the immune system of the fish on its
organizations
yes the zebrafish model is usually used
to see the immunity fish and human
pathologies immune mechanisms but still
there is still a huge need to better
understand the anatomical organization
of the adult zebrafish human system and
if i were to summarize a bit so here you
have a very nice zebrafish
and you have the head with the virtual
cavity and then you have the kidneys
thymus and spleen so there is two
uh primary lymphatic organ the thymus
on the kidney marrow kidney marrow this
is where you have the hematopoiesis
but the kidney arrow is also sites of a
social function of secondary lymphatic
tissue
which also have the spleen then of
course
uh we can consider that the fish is a
huge mucosa because all its interface
with the empire knot is made of because
of tissues
so you have um lymphatic issue
associated to those because they like in
the nostrils the guilt
the guts on the skin and of course you
can
uh have inductive structures such as
melanoma macrophage centers on
granulomatous
the thing is if you look into these
mucosal tissues
what is perceived wrongly is that
it's just like diffuse and organized of
scattered immune cells
in those mucosal tissue which is a bit
odd thinking when you think about the
fish in these natural habitat they will
be exposed to pathogens you would expect
the microbial tissue to be a bit more
sophisticated on the tree there has been
some more structures now that are being
more structured infra tissue that are
not being discovered
that will go a bit so but my main areas
of interest is the bolshoi cavity
so basically if you look at the fish
from from the back
you would see the pyramids in green for
example in the middle and
the bonus activity would make two
cavities on each side
and then you would have four pairs of
kill arches
the water would be breathed through the
mouth goes into the pharynx
reach each virtual cavity
irrigates the gills on the expelled by
openings
if we look at what gills actually look
like so while here actually is a bit
because this is built from salmon it's a
bit bigger a bit easier to
be more easy to uh to show on uh
explain all the gila structures so
basically at the bottom you have a
supportive structure
called the gill arch very cartilaginous
and then from this gill arch you have
some kind of trees that arise
on each side so if you make from the
substitution for this you see like the
arch and then you have these two trees
called filament
and that in between the filaments you
have another supportive structure it's
called the septum
and when i spoke about having structured
into tissue
here you have one of you that has been
found in norway in salmon first so that
we recently
showed existed in zebrafish as well is
called the entire broncholin3 tissue
that we just call ilt that is on top of
the septum and along the
inner side of the filament of course
if you look we want to look into
zebrafish so this is the breakfast guild
so here you have a bit of the pharynx in
the middle then you can recognize
the gill arch so this little spine here
called
gil's wrecker there are two presents put
bigger
particles to to be into the guild
then you have these small trees called
filaments and then you see that these
little
little flaps to the side they're called
lamellae and this is
where the gas exchange occurs and if we
were to to make
uh again a transfer sensation for the
guild
because when this study wanted to to
look at the organization of the
zebrafish steel associated liquid tissue
so we take this kind of imaging and
again we have fluidine in green and that
in blue and we label t
cells in red and
if we take into consideration the
labeling of t cells
on the compatimentalization of the kills
we could find
that the g out was uh
could be divided in five sections
one is this entire control limit you see
on top of the steps of
thumb right here so on top of it on the
on in the side
of the filament then there is three
regions
like in the other part of the filament
on
the the bonsol arc there
the t-cell are just scattered but then
something interesting is we could see on
the sides
each side of the gale arch right here on
the ear at the base of the filament
something that looks a bit more
clustered so it's a new linkage issue
that we thought and called the
antibronchial
infrared tissue of alt heat short
so we tried to characterize that a bit
more and you can see with a
zoom where you have two different gill
arch you can see very well the sketch
with t-cells
on the guild arch and then when you
reach to this place
you see that the t-cells are a lot more
clustered
so then we want our case so but this is
just some kind of
loose tissue loose aggregate of t-cells
or it's structured
so what we did is we labeled um
phytokeratin because because cytokine
will then reveal
the reticulated epithelial cells that
you usually find in structured lipid
tissue
so you find them in the ilt which was
shown in salmon
and in this new lymphatic issue the alt
we could find that it was the same so
this
is this seems to be like a structural
lymphatic issue
if we look at this small scheme
subjectively we have the kilash the two
filaments
lamellae lt and then you would have on
the two side the alt
but still we wondered uh is it some kind
of
aggregate that we find sometimes or is
it continuous for the whole length
of the of the arch so in this case i
have to dissect
very carefully into the damage the gills
which are very fragile
and make one month staining with that 70
and then again
that are acquired with the dragonfly and
you can see
that uh this is continuous you see
everything there
all the t cells in white we're
continuously you can see
all the guild wreckers the gill arch the
filaments on the flaps
there you have the t-cells you see
continuous this is the alt
i'll just let you enjoy the videos just
to see to look at the 3d of the gill
archer
then we could see that you see it goes
on along the side but then it makes
small penetrations in between the
filament so it seems also to zigzag a
bit
in between the filaments which is quite
quite interesting
and as you can see that the resolution
is very very good on
this is very quick to acquire
i think takes maybe like five eight
minutes
maximum for three different colors
so that's how we could find actually the
the organization of the kill associated
lymphede tissue find a new structured
lymph with tissue in it
and anyone okay but uh what if we
actually
uh change the level actually look at the
world virtual cavity level
so there actually we did the same thing
as i showed you in the previous videos
we have this um
multiple through the view acquisitions
on transaction
through the ventral cavity and as you
can see on the roof of the bunch of
cavities you have the timers
here you the t cells are in white the
actin is in
green and nuclei in blue and as you can
see
we could see that there was some kind of
continuity of the t
sustaining from the timers to the gains
actually that
most of the parts in the module kft were
interconnected together
but the main surprise that we got is
when we then started to look
at the lower parts of the branch of
cavity
we actually could find a new lymph with
organ that we call the nemosian liquid
organ
so if we just look in this image
the t cells are in red followed in green
aren't
dappy in blue you you have the two bunch
of cavity
you have the gill artists one and two
one and two
then you have the yogurt yellow bone
right here
and then we see all these structures
heavily loaded
with t-cells actually in the in the
isthmus in the parts between the two
control cavity that connects
and we could see that in many different
ways so of course we characterize that
a lot more on the paper it's very close
to submission
now but we could use that for example
and with the collaboration with
montpellier
that make layer by layer imaging focal
microscope merge with the brussels
we could actually recompose the 3d
structure of this neuron so this is all
the name of the
nucleus looks actually if you have to
replace with the ends of the fish on the
bronchial cavity so here you have the
two timers on top
this is the localizations right in the
middle of this new lymphatic organ
so you can see the zebrafish just
allowed us with live imaging to find new
biological mechanisms regarding
nanoparticles
and then just to explore the immune
system of the fish we could find new
lymphede structures
on newly production so
i would like to thanks uh well you
fought
for atoning this show and also
uh to acknowledge uh garrett griffiths
my pi to allow me to have the the
freedom to do the research
that i like all the different
collaborators involved in the different
projects and of course um
on their own language staff as well as
the
the imaging festivity normic that i'm
being using
and from which i get a great support
so yeah if you have any questions so the
christian and unsurpations will be
at the end of the of the talk of claudia
and yeah i'm going to turn it over to
claudia so yeah
it's all yours
so thank you very much julian and thank
you so much for
your excellent presentation i did enjoy
it quite a lot
seeing multiple uses of the zebra fish
and now i will follow up with a very
quick
overview of the dragonfly which was the
microscope that julian used to do most
of his
very nice microscopy data
so as you saw from julian's presentation
there's extremely it is extremely
important to integrate
the cells also the nanostructures within
the cells
and to integrate all that information in
the whole
organism and we at andor we do believe
that we have the perfect system
that allows you to analyze the nano
information
the structures on the cells and also the
whole
organism so starting by comparison the
dragonfly with multi-point
with single point scanning confocals so
as you can see immediately in this image
when you're using point scanning
confocal the image is scanned
point by point by point and the
dragonfly due to its
multi-point confocal technology will
deliver an
image in an instant and that's why we
say we have an instant confocal
also because of its dual micro lens
system we have
high efficiency in capturing the light
not only that
but the dragonfly benefits from angle
andors emc cds and
scmos technology which delivers quantum
efficiencies
up to 90 percent whereas point scanning
confocals
the quantum efficiencies are around 45
percent
so you we have better efficiency in
capturing the light
so as an overall key specifications of
the dragonfly
we deliver a very fast confocal with
speeds
in confocal mode up to 400 frames per
second
it has a very wide field of view with a
22 millimeter diagonal
so this will increase your productivity
because you need to acquire less images
to have
this larger field of view
and we deliver a very wide excitation
range of wavelength from the 405
nearly 800 nanometers excitation
and it has a very flat uniform spectrum
across the whole excitation wavelength
and our detectors deliver 16 bit
gray levels nearly 6 more than 65 000
gray levels so the dragonfly
multipoint confocal is what we say
a multi-modal high contrast multi-modal
platform
as i just told you it is a confocal an
instant confocal
multi-point confocal but you can also
use the dragonfly to have
lasers wide field imaging or
you can also have super resolution
techniques
such as this storm and surf stream or
even you can use the dragonfly
for turf imaging and all of these in a
single
imaging system as i just told you you
have from visible to the near
infrared wavelength with the driver fly
and now i will pass to show you some
imaging applications that you can use
with the dragonfly so you design you can
use the dragonfly for deep imaging
applications and you can image up to
millimeters deep
in tissues or you can image different
tissues and simultaneously acquire
live imaging data or acquire live
emerging data and simultaneously
acquire double color leveling and if you
combine it with search stream
you can acquire super resolution images
images that break the diffraction limit
of light
far beyond the edge of the coverslip
so one example of this is this clear
tissue
that it's 2.4 millimeters depth
imaged with under dragonfly
and because we we deliver a very broad
uniform illumination spectrum due to our
borealis patent illumination delivery
you can see that with some systems you
can actually see
the image the tiles when you do the
image
but using the boreal is perfect
illumination
you don't see the tiles so you have
seamless
stitching perfect illumination across
the whole
field of view and what does this do that
if you want to image
a full fish as julia was just saying
imaging the zebra fish but in this case
for example i could be interesting
in the eye in imaging the details on the
eye
but i also want to see the whole fish so
i can acquire with a high magnification
lens
and i can acquire multiple tiles because
the system is quite fast
and i have the detail at every scale
from the nanometer till the millimeter
and for example in this case where we
image the neurons
and this is in the mouth brain tissue
and you can see this was
more than 5 500 images acquired
in 25 image 25 minutes
so you have montage and montage with
deep imaging and you can see the neuron
and the neuron integrated with its
neighboring
cells
moving on to live imaging in live
imaging
challenges the greatest challenges
actually is to avoid photo toxicity
because in the end of the movie
you want to have the cells alive and you
don't want that which what you are
seeing is effect
due to degradation and due to too much
light
but also when you go over the photo
toxicity you also want to avoid photo
bleaching because in the end of the
movie you still want to have
signal enough in in order to be able to
analyze your data
and many times researchers need to
compromise
need to decrease the light need to
decrease the temporal resolution or the
spatial resolution
but because we deliver a system that is
extremely gentle
in imaging and extremely efficient in
capturing the light
we do believe that with the dragonfly
you don't need to compromise
and so i will show you some examples as
for
here we were imaging live inside the
institut
in testing imaging deep the blood flow
and this was acquired at 200 frames per
second
with under scmos camera and you can
actually see
the blood flow if you want to break the
resolution limit you can use self stream
self stream yields an increase in
resolution between two
to six times in the final data
and due to its low power requirements it
is compatible with live cell imaging
and surfstream algorithm allows
acquisition of super resolved images
deep inside the cells and tissues and
you can compare here
the same fixed cells in this case where
i wanted to show
the improvement in resolution from no
surf to
to a surf stream image
another application that you can use the
dragonfly for
is multiplex imaging or spatial result
prescriptomics
special results transcriptomics or
multiplex imaging
are is a group of methods that deliver
information
at the single molecule rna level of
expression
of numerous genes so these methods are
extremely important because they allow
the discovery of new biomarkers identify
new cell types in responses to diseases
and injuries
they can reveal an atlas of gene
expression of a
2d or 3d tissue and they can identify
uh temporal and spatial gene expression
patterns
and how this is done well this is then
integrating the dragonfly imaging system
with a microfluidic devices
and imaging yourself imaging your sample
doing barcodes and doing multiple rounds
of a
hybridization and stripping and then
with a dragonfly
ultra fast imaging system doing multiple
rounds and you will have
rounds enough to deliver the number of
genes products that you want
to analyze we do
offer at andor a full complex imaging
system
from acquisition to analysis and upon
acquiring
your imaging data you can go to image
workstation
and analyze your imaging data and in
this case for example
trace your vessels
so the dragonfly comes in two models we
do offer the dragonfly 500 and the
dragonfly 200.
the dragonfly 500 is the complete
imaging system in which you have
all the the imaging modalities
as turf the super resolution and also
it can be combined with and or photo
stimulation devices for example if you
combine it with mosaics for optogenetics
to analyze in cancer research
self-proliferation and cell invasion or
in neurosciences for example you can use
turf to analyze
neural cone dynamics and forming
connections
the dragonfly 200 is offered as a more
compact solution and is offered in
upright and inverted systems
you can use it for developmental biology
studies for example you can also combine
it
with under fossil stimulation devices
such as micro point
for laser ablation you can use it for
cardiovascular studies for vascular
damage and repair
again you can combine it with under
fossil simulation device or for
neurosciences
these are very versatile devices that
microscopes that you can use for
multiple applications
and this is just an example of multiple
publications that have been used with
dragon five so with the dragonfly
we are very proud to say that
researchers like julia
do publish science that in high impact
journals
and we are extremely proud to deliver
and to help those researchers to push
science further and with this
i will finish and i'm happy to touch
any questions thank you very much for
listening
thank you dr resegier and dr florindo
for your informative presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
very impressive imaging can this also be
extended to study pathogens
uh very good questions
um i mean definitely there's a lot
of vlad now that are using the zebrafish
to study ostrophotogenic interaction the
state
from different viruses different
bacteria parasites
also even the the corn virus there is no
preprints
that are available and i think that the
paper will be published very soon
so it is yes a very good system to
strategy
pathogens on diseases
okay our next question is
let's see where did it go um
great talk i have two questions one can
you target the nanoparticles to a
specific type of cell
and deliver drugs specifically to let's
say peripheral neurons
and two what software imaging system was
used for the t-cell infiltration
after viral infection video
well um thank you for the second time
of um uh that's a bit of a tricky
questions because
it really depends on which way you want
to administer
the nanoparticles how long you want them
to impact
and also which part of the body and for
peripheral neurons
then you have to figure if you inject it
intravenously you have to think of a
strategy
so they would cross the the blood
the endotheliums the basement membrane
and then reach
these special neurons uh i think that's
um yeah that's very tricky to answer
um i will go to the second part of the
question
so i think you refer to the to the very
large brain images
with the infection of the
mycosporidia norosilia so for that the
software was immersed
well you make the videos with imares
and you try to crop to work with it and
then you can under end up with it
with uh imagej but um just to to say
this set of image was more than 100
gigabytes so you need also a very good
computer to be able to uh to work on it
thank you julian and we have another
question here
we have been using zebrafish larva for
mycobacterial infections
any idea if the nanoparticle imaging can
be used for bacterial infections
uh yes actually well some data
i did not present but we also work on
delivering new therapeutic compounds to
granulomatic tuberculosis granuloma
so definitely you you can do that and
actually the
the laboratory of garlic has been
publishing two papers
uh two recent first one that showed that
macrophages could internalize
nanoparticles and migrate to the site of
mycobacterium granuloma and also that if
you inject it intravenously they would
also accumulate
at the granular site of the time so that
you you can check the literature of
garrett prefix on your triangles two
pages
dr ferendo would you have anything that
you would like to add
okay not sure if i can hear dr florendo
but we will definitely come back to you
if you have anything that you need to
say
i will move on to the next question
um stunning pictures i am working on an
osteoporosis
is that you dr florino
no no okay i am working on
an osteoporosis model of zebrafish what
is your recommendation
uh imaging technologies for drug
screening
using scale
uh i would go for well uh scalar quite
thin
as a breakfast so you should be able to
do 3d imaging
using the dragonfly very well uh you
could also use some uh well i don't need
i don't think you need to go with the
light sheet i think it's not
big enough but that could also be a
possibility
but then uh if you were not to use just
regular bones for osteoporosis like
all this 3d imaging if you take the fish
you fix it
on your protected and decalcify it with
edta
uh you can also do this uh wall organism
sections are trying to look of a
different set of bones all the impacts
of the different drugs
i hope that answer you your question
okay thank you julian um
dr florindo are you are you still there
i i am still here can you listen to me i
can hear you now yes
yes finally if there's something that
you would like to say that we passed
over please go ahead and say that
yeah i was uh when uh julian was talking
about
the emma so it's just wanting to say
that
we do offer with a dragonfly that julian
used for acquisition
we do offer an end-to-end solution and
the mars comes integrated with the
dragonfly system
for analysis and creating those neutral
movies that you have been
seeing in the presentation and sorry for
the
technical problems that's okay i think
we're all kind of used to technical
problems now with this year of being
on zoom and webinars and so we i think
we all understand i'm so glad you got a
chance to speak
uh okay so let me uh ask one another
question here we have time for just a
few more
can we get xyz coordinate information
from dragonfly
[Music]
[Applause]
yes so the the dragonfly is
a multimodal system that is delivered by
and or
technology and you have two
uh it's a multi-point speeding this
confocal
so it is a confocal imaging system but
it also delivers
other imaging technologies so you can do
a confocal you can do white field
imaging
you can do surf stream with a dragonfly
you can do turf and you can do a
storm and 3d storm we do have two
different types of the dragonfly
dragon 500 and 200
so if you want to have more information
with the dragonfly we'll be
happy to come back to you offline
with the android technologies
uh thank you so much uh claudia we've
got another
last question i think this is also for
you uh for multiplex
imaging how is the interaction between
the dragonfly and the external devices
achieved
so for uh thank you so much for that
question
and for the multiplex imaging
the the interaction is done by the
resting
api interface which is incorporated into
the fusion software
so it can the the external devices can
be controlled
by an external program that can be
driven by
python labview or matlab and this
provides the ability for fusion to
communicate
with the for dragonfly to communicate
with the microfluidic devices
through fusion and to proceed to the
multiple rounds of
imaging and and and washing
integrating with the microfluidic system
thank you dr rescuer and dr florindo
do you have any final comments for our
audience today
so julia please go ahead
well uh well thanks for attending
the the webinar um so thanks a lot uh
to dr florando uh for the invitations
to perform this seminar uh i hope that
uh after this presentations he would be
convinced
of how hopeful is this about his model
for light imaging
that you would also consider uh
all the great improvements that have
been done on the spinning distance
microscope on that all the things that
you can achieve with it
so yeah that was my favorite world
so as for my final words the first big
thank you i would like to give is for dr
julian
who was kind enough to present his work
and these awesome
images and uh and thank you our roots
for
uh giving us the chance to present our
system
and i would like to say to every
everyone that we do
have an outstanding imaging system a
spinning disc confocal microscope that
allows you to
acquire confocal images quite fast
and deliver explained
resolution so please contact andor if
you want to know more about the
dragonfly
and this is all from my side
thank you again dr rezagier and dr
florindo for your
time today and for your important
research we would also like to thank
labrus and our sponsor
andor for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
libraries will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye